the calendar of the future needs to know
that there's traffic on road to my
meeting and prom me to leave 20 minutes
early calendar hasn't changed in
thousands of years in fact if you were
to strip away UI and Logo there's very
little difference in feature function
the only Innovation that really happened
is people took these calendars and
brought it on the web so I think we'll
we'll need to find a way to display the
thei different Fleet go back 20 years
and you look at and say what was the
real limiting factor for people who
pushing their professional envelope it
was what technology could get could you
put in their hands where are people
going where are they right now for what
uh we're at very much the early stages
of it it isn't just necessarily you know
schedule this or schedule that but it's
all the things that are going on in your
life and how you TI in and that's what's
really exciting now the floodgates have
opened you I've got the Blackberry I've
got the the iPhone I've got the iPad
I've got the laptop I've got the desktop
and then the list goes on you've got
your coffee in one hand you've got your
mobile on the other I mean you can't
spend time like clicking away you look
at the Outlook you look at Google uh
Lotus Notes pretty much the same thing
for for all how do you take a fresh eye
to it and come up with something that's
that's a new mhm you click on it it
zooms your mobile has to be intelligent
I want to be on my phone right and just
click on the calendar and see everything
get it on you know I think Google
deserves some credit for doing a little
bit when it comes to experimenting with
public versus private entries and
calendars if we all live in public and
and I can watch you all day
long now I can see patterns in your life
that you might not even know exist I'm
big on Facebook and Twitter and blogging
and photo sharing and all that stuff so
share share share a calendar is a really
important part of a social network you
know you got the checking guys like
force and goala we've got all these
social applications and location based
services that are out there now that
everybody's flocking to and they're all
disperate streams of data all these
different sources need an anchor and
this anchor is your calendar I'm a
calendar guy so I would rather go to my
calendar and see there's my rental car
uh reservation number there's my hotel
reservation there's my flight it's
becoming more and more intelligent
because it knows where you've been who
you're meeting what you're doing what
you're going to be doing so now your
calendar can work for you what everybody
does have is that feeling of stress when
you have three things to do right that's
stress my goal is to remove that stress
and if I tried to do a retrospective of
how did I spend my time last month last
year analytics on calendar Nobody Does
that calendar of the future should help
me to optimize the way I spend my time
so I can get more accomplished in a day
how do I use the calendar to more
effectively manage my day as opposed to
my day being managed by the calendar the
calendar of the future is not so far
away everything becomes an optimization
I think technolog is an incredible
enabler and once the enabler is in place
now I think the the the bar that people
are setting for themselves for how do we
deliver value to professionals is to
start tuning what comes through that
enabling system sure and so that's an
active optimization probably at its
purest form you guys are really thinking
much further ahead than anyone else that
uh that I've seen in the space so I I
think that's uh critically important